[Music]
all the way from south korea black pink
black
[Applause]
[Music]
we brought together seven black pink
fans i am a black pink fan i'm a black
pink fan i'm a black pink fan i am a
black pink fan i am a black pink fan i'm
a black pink fan i'm a black pink fan
one is a hater if the group discovers
who the liar is they'll split a cash
prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
who is the odd one out
i have a good idea before we start let's
all start how blackpink takes the stage
and if you know one two three go right
if you know you know ready everybody one
two three you go just like black pig
ready one two three i've already loved
one two three
first round when i didn't know the chant
like my my confidence were like that i
was like damn am i even a fan if i don't
know this chant like let's just start
with like how and when we got to black
pink i've gone to black paint like even
during pre-debut during like [ __ ] but i
have my money dance practice okay
i got into black pink um during playing
with fire i think yeah playing fire to
me he seemed a little out of place he
looked more like
he liked twice
during the pandemic my cousin got me
into bts and then out of bts i got into
explore k-pop girl groups and then i
found black pink and i was like these
are
oh my god they're sorry they're so cool
i've already cussing
i got to them in 2016. um like them
since debut i loved 2anyone and then i
was like
that's exactly how i wanted something to
fill that void i was there since debut i
just watched a documentary and i was
hooked you weren't doing the documentary
yes
so like for i'm pretty new he said that
he only got into black pink when the
documentary came out so he knows a
little bit too much for somebody who's
gone to blackpink during the pandemic
wait what's up with these biases
i hear your name chanel the only one i
remember because i'm like human chanel
yeah
okay cool all right cool cool just
making sure you're sure
oh we're running out of time
[Music]
in round one i voted for noey he almost
looked scared when i was looking at him
when when we did the one two three go
[Music]
i voted for catherine just because she
had a look that i felt suspicious about
okay
i guess i couldn't really speak a lot
i'm just kind of disappointed that i
wasn't able to showcase a lot of the
different things i wanted to talk about
um
yeah do you know where every member's
from where they were born yes where are
they from uh jesus from korea i mean she
was born in korea and raised in korea um
rose
is from went to new zealand that went to
australia and lived in australia
um
oh my god jenny is from new zealand
and then lisa's thai
my mind was so set on noe after round
one but then when no we started talking
a lot i had to kind of go okay i know
he's no he's safe wait has anyone seen
them in concert oh i have
i went to the one in la i was actually
sponsored by kia because they they were
like oh she's such a fan let's bring her
so at first catherine i was like she's a
mole and she's just like putting on a
front like it could be your friends i
also didn't know if she was just like a
general k-pop fan but not a black pink
fan you got your eye on me but like i
could like say how much i'm like i'm
like a blank
[Laughter]
what do you guys feel about jesus solo
well she don't got one exceptional
what do you guys think about their
collaborations with u.s artists i don't
like the cardi b i don't like it either
honestly
i like sour candy and kiss the makeup
sour candy's
ian is very quiet he doesn't seem to be
inputting that much
i just voted for chanelle because she
was quiet i felt bad she was so nice too
i just i didn't know
[Music]
you're so cute wow i hate all your men
love kids
i expected it because there was a lot of
aggression going on in the back and i
wasn't really saying much it's just that
i really got caught up in the moment of
observing if everyone feels confident
that you already caught them all you can
end the game now but if the majority has
doubt the game will continue please
raise your hand if you want to continue
playing the game
really
okay
that is majority
for every time all of you vote out
someone that is not the mole the total
prize money will be reduced
why why did you think that everybody was
caught why didn't you think the mole was
not here i feel like everyone is really
confident about like chanel still five
of us here the odds of the mole being in
here are still really high well i
definitely felt ganged up in that round
because it's like they're really trying
to figure out the mole but i thought
we'd already gotten it out i honestly
felt like the mole was the first person
we had eliminated should we start doing
dances the choreo any chores
ready dances no no no no no just one at
a time let's do one at a time everybody
do a separate song okay
hannah do set how you like that
so round three i was like okay i guess
i'm pulling out some dance moves like
let me just pull something out of my ass
like do a little dance like hopefully
like these people will believe me
hey
who's everybody's main suspicion right
now because i'm still very suspicious of
you he's not gonna lie
i honestly i feel like it's between you
two i do have to say i will admit that i
am more casual i'm not like completely
die hard but i do but that doesn't mean
you're not a fan that's cool yes i do
okay
do you have any merch no i don't have
anymore i'm gonna bring that back on you
i couldn't afford a light stick at the
concert so i just like
so i voted for ian round three because
everybody else seems like they know what
they're talking about and ian was the
most um
quiet one
i feel like noey could have been the
mole because he said he didn't buy any
merch
we counted all the votes and we have a
tie
the tie is between
noey
and eve
what i gotta do wow
that means we're going into a second
round of votes between the two i have to
pick this one
i changed my mind
wow
i was like seriously seriously you're
gonna eliminate me and it's just gonna
have your money so
please raise your hand if you want to
continue playing the game
we will end the game now if the lights
turn green that means you have voted out
the mall and you win if the lights turn
red that means the mole is still in the
box and you
lose
[Applause]
even as it was pretty green i was like
nah they're lying this isn't real and
then and then i was like oh no we
actually won well the fake black pink
fan please step forward and reveal
yourself in three
two
one
oh my god
[Applause]
you could have got more money if you
didn't roll me off i was not surprised
at all i instantly knew i was a black
pink fan it is
one of the groups that got me back into
k-pop but i slowly took all their music
off my playlist and i was like i just
don't like their sound anymore and then
ever since they went to the american
market and with like
ice cream that came out and honestly
like all the collabs kind of suck not
gonna lie
in my opinion he's allowed to say this
all right he got his opinion he's
allowed to have it let's not get crazy
on the comments destroy me in the
comments
i have a couple of their flashiest
albums the show is my favorite they're
really powerful they work hard for what
they do they're not just influencers
anyone can enjoy black pink i don't know
they're fun and also
look how beautiful my photo cards are oh
i love them so much i think for me why
blackpink stood out to me kpop was the
other to me you know because i don't
speak korean well and so for me it's
always been a thing of like
embarrassment that i can't speak korean
well when i see these k-pop people
speaking fluent english i'm like oh i
can relate to this we want to thank you
all for participating so we want to gift
you all with something
[Applause]
[Music]
since you guys messed up once no leave a
little bit
oh i forgot it's so sad
we throw this on
oh wait wait wait roll it oh
[Applause]